Well those so-called COVID
issues.
Hear haven't stopped her from
visiting the rest of the country
with COVID issues she's traveled
coast to coast all since being
tapped to lead the border
response here with reaction
Texas GOP Congressman and former
Sheriff Troy nail's Sheriff good
morning to you good morning,
Steve.
Good morning, everyone.
So she says we have to deal with
COVID issues COVID is an issue
everywhere what's she worried
about is she worried that she
might get it because she's been
vaccinated or is she worried
that they coming in have
a higher infection rate or what
are these common issues
that's the excuse that this
administration is going to use
and look at her.
She's been jet setting around
this country going to all
the different blue states
talking about this this
infrastructure plan
and everything else so no this
isn't covered Kamala and you
know it you just don't want
to visit the southern border
because you know what
you're going to hear
you're going to hear from
the border patrol Department
of public safety immigration
small town mayor and everyone
that lives along that southern
border that you are doing
a horrible job
you're in complete denial
and you need to fix the southern
border that's what she would
hear if she visited it
so she's going to use the excuse
like everything else Yeah you
know you've got to wonder when
she says there's a COVID issue
if you're talking about
the danger there would that mean
that our border patrol
enforcement people would be
in peril just by simply being
down there if there's a COVID
issue well of course when this
president has invited just about
everyone from Central America
come on up into our great United
States of America these
individuals are bringing disease
with them.
In addition to but I mean,
we have to make sure that
the individuals that are
in our southern border are
actually tested but we know we
haven't reached that point yet
and so I just think that it is
a poor excuse but what what what
else was she going to say
she's got to come up with some
excuse COVID just seems to be
the word of the day every day
and probably for the next
several weeks or months they
know how to handle this quite
honestly well you're right it
does seem like that is
the messaging going forward Fox
News did a poll and looked
at border security today
as opposed to two years ago.
And as you can see the biggest
number they're in it now is that
it's worse now than it was
before, and we saw an earlier
poll from another outfit that
said that a majority of people
feel that the reason
our southern border is a magnet
is because of Joe Biden's policy
that's pretty clear he made that
clear during the campaign
and now we shouldn't be shocked
that this is happening down
there it is his policy this is
a crisis this is just out listen
the Biden administration they
actually enjoy this, which is
sad they do not put the American
people first and I've said this
several times.
I said we must put America first
but they added a word into it
they're putting Central America
first she wants to go down
and visit Guatemala and Honduras
she doesn't want to go down
to our southern border
and it's we need to continue
to keep up the pressure we need
to continue to have cadence go
visit the southern border
and talk about this issue show
the American people the crisis
we have at the southern border
and this is such an easy fix
state revert back
to Trump's policy come out
you're in charge of this now
remember you're the the point
person on this you need to get
up this morning you need to call
President
Trump and ask him say sir how
did you have such a secure
southern border and he'll tell
her you need to go back
to the Remain in Mexico you need
to get rid of this catch
and release and you need
to finish the wall that's how we
solve this problem and it could
be done today I got a feeling
she's not going to make that
phone call.
But I do have a question.
I don't know if you're going
to be going
to the president's address
before Congress on Wednesday
night but what exact question
what is the one thing you would
like to hear from Joe Biden I
would like to hear Joe Biden
Let's play his speech on January
20 let's go in and play some
of this speech where he talked
about bipartisanship
and and working with my friends
on the other side of the aisle
and then I would like to ask
them the question how do you
think you've done so far
because there is no
bipartisanship we are a divided
country you said earlier
in your poll that 82% of America
Americans feel that we are
divided
we certainly are and as he
continues to just placate that
far left freak show of hands
we're never going to come
together as a country all right
Congressman nail's we thank you
very much for joining us today
from down in the Houston area
thank you, sir.
Thank you.
God bless All right.